From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt，代班 Ira Glass。
When Shirin Jaafari moved to the US as a young adult, there were a lot of promises made to her family back home. We'll be in touch all the time, call you every week, almost like we're in the same town, which is the kind of thing you say. But Shirin actually pulled this off for the last 20 years.
Shirin Jaafari 成年初期搬到美国时，曾给家乡的父母许下许多承诺。我们说：我们会一直保持联系，每周通电话，就像住在一个镇子上一样。这通常只是客套话，但 Shirin 过去20年里真的做到了。
We are a close family. We message several times a day. We send each other reels, like, normal stuff. I mean, I don't want to lose those details, those small details of their lives, because I am so far away from them.
我们家关系很亲密。我们每天发好几次信息。我们互相分享短视频，就像普通人那样。我是说，我不想失去那些细节，那些他们生活中的琐碎细节，因为我离他们太远了。
And they really get into the details, this family-- who ate what, how far was the walk, what's the latest with the dental work? On the phone, by text, random thoughts tossed out at any hour-- have you seen this pumpkin dessert? Unsolicited suggestions.
这一家人真的很注重细节——谁吃了什么，走路走了多远，牙齿治疗进展如何？通过电话、短信，随时随地抛出随机的想法——你看到这款南瓜甜点了吗？各种不请自来的建议。
I would send them videos of exercises they can do at home.
我会发给他们一些可以在家做的锻炼视频。
Like you worrying about them getting enough movement?
就像担心他们运动量不足一样？
I would love them to-- yes, I have been trying to get my mom to do more yoga and my dad to not sit all day.
我很想让他们……是的，我一直试图让我妈多练练瑜伽，让我爸不要整天坐着。
How's that going?
效果怎么样？
Not great.
不太好。
So just like a constant, ongoing conversation with them.
所以就像是和他们进行一场持续不断的对话。
Totally, the kind of thing that you would be asking them if you were actually in the same space and close.
没错，就是那种如果你真的和他们住在同一个地方，关系亲密时会问他们的事情。
Then in February, the United States and Israel attacked Iran, where her parents live. And on that very same day, the first day of the war, the Iranian authorities shut the internet down, just put the whole country into an internet blackout, a shockingly effective blackout.
二月，美国和以色列袭击了她父母居住的伊朗。就在那天，战争的第一天，伊朗当局切断了互联网，让整个国家陷入了断网状态，一种令人震惊的高效停电式断网。
The call wouldn't go through. It would just disconnect. I didn't hear anything. It would just disconnect.
电话打不通。总是自动挂断。我什么都听不到。总是断开。
Did you do it over and over again?
你试了很多次吗？
Yes, of course. I tried so many times. I wouldn't be able to get through. Calling through cell phone was impossible. It just became useless. The cell phone became useless for us. The only way I was able to communicate with them was them calling on a landline to my cell phone. That was the only way they could reach me.
是的，当然。我试了无数次。根本打不通。用手机呼叫是不可能的。手机变得毫无用处。手机对我们来说彻底失效了。我唯一能联系他们的方法就是他们用座机打我的手机。那是他们联系我的唯一方式。
Text message, email-- nothing else was working?
短信、邮件——其他什么都不行了？
After that point, no. They called me on the landline. And it's funny when I think of it-- there were so many times when I visit them and I would tell them, who needs a landline? Maybe you guys should get rid of this. In this day and age, who needs a landline?
那之后，什么都不行了。他们只能打我的座机。回想起来真可笑，我有好多次去看望他们时都会说，谁还需要座机啊？你们也许应该把它撤掉。在这个年代，谁还需要座机呢？
Inside Iran, what was happening was, as soon as the war started, cell phones were only working to call people inside the country, no internet. Communication with the outside world became so difficult, it was like going from breathing regularly out in the open to being underwater and breathing through a straw. Workarounds like VPNs are expensive or janky. Some are flat-out scams. And they're banned. A private satellite service like Starlink? Illegal. And people have been arrested for using it.
在伊朗国内，战争一爆发，手机就只能拨打国内电话，没有互联网。与外界的沟通变得极其困难，就像从正常呼吸的户外被扔进水里，只能通过一根吸管呼吸。VPN 等变通方法要么昂贵，要么不稳定。有些干脆就是诈骗。而且它们是被禁止的。私人卫星服务（如星链）？非法。已经有人因为使用它而被捕了。
So the landline-- that was the only way Shirin's parents could reach her. But when bombing got too intense in Tehran, they fled the city, leaving behind the landline. And Shirin was left going for days, sometimes weeks, without hearing from them. Were they OK? Were they safe? She'd go on social media, scouring every platform, looking for anyone she knew in Iran who had found some brief internet workaround to ask them if they'd heard from her parents.
所以座机是 Shirin 父母联系她的唯一途径。但当德黑兰的轰炸变得太激烈时，他们逃离了城市，抛弃了座机。Shirin 只能一连几天，甚至几周都听不到他们的消息。他们还好吗？他们安全吗？她会登录社交媒体，搜遍每一个平台，寻找她在伊朗认识的任何可能找到上网渠道的人，询问他们是否听到过她父母的消息。
So sometimes I would stay up at like, 3:00 or 4:00 AM, looking for any information that I can get from any relative or friend or somebody who knows my parents that could be online. I would just send messages to everybody, like, hey, let me know if you are online. Let me know the next time you're connected. Can you give me an update? Just message me as soon as you see this message.
有时我会熬到凌晨三四点，寻找任何能从亲戚、朋友或任何认识我父母且可能在线的人那里得到的信息。我会给所有人发消息，比如，嘿，如果你在线请告诉我。下次上线时告诉我。你能给我更新一下吗？看到这条消息请立即回复我。
I've heard a lot in the last two months during this war about deals and negotiations. I've heard about bombings by the US and Israel, and by Iran. Also lots about oil prices and the stock market, and the Strait of Hormuz. But I haven't heard much at all from Iranians inside Iran. What are they seeing, and thinking, and doing, and talking about?
在过去两个月的战争中，我听到了很多关于协议和谈判的消息。我听说了美国、以色列和伊朗的轰炸。还听说了大量关于油价、股市和霍尔木兹海峡的消息。但我几乎没听到伊朗国内伊朗人的声音。他们在看什么、想什么、做什么、谈论什么？
For the last few weeks, we've been working with two journalists in the United States, Fatemeh Jamalpour and Roxana Saberi, to collect voice memos from inside Iran. So many people sent messages, even though it was difficult and dangerous for them to get these messages out. But people wanted to be heard. I have not heard anything like these from inside Iran. I guess that's part of the point of an internet blackout.
过去几周，我们与美国的两位记者 Fatemeh Jamalpour 和 Roxana Saberi 合作，收集了来自伊朗境内的语音备忘录。很多人发送了消息，尽管这对他们来说既困难又危险。但人们渴望被倾听。我以前从未听过来自伊朗国内这样的声音。我想这就是互联网断网的目的之一。
So that's what I want to share with you. Today's show, we hear from people inside Iran, where war is only part of what's going on for them. That's coming up. Stay with us.
所以这就是我想分享给大家的。今天的节目，我们将听到来自伊朗内部的声音，在那里，战争只是他们生活的一部分。稍后回来，请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Today's episode, Blackout. Other places have had their internet cut off during a war. Iran is not the first. But this isn't something that's being imposed on the country from the outside. It's being done by the leadership of the country to its own citizens while they're being attacked-- in this case by us, the United States, and Israel.
这里是《美国生活》。今天的主题是“断网”。在战争期间，其他地方也曾经历过互联网中断。伊朗不是第一个。但这不是外部强加给这个国家的，而是由国家的领导层在其国民正遭受攻击——在这种情况下，是由我们美国和以色列——的同时对他们自己公民实施的。
Listening to these messages that people sent us, you really get the feeling for how total a blackout is. I had the thought, listening over and over, that every part of what they're saying is not supposed to be heard, even basic things like, what are people doing every day? A blackout is not a censorship that goes line by line. It is wholesale redaction of people's lives, and sometimes deaths.
听着人们发来的这些消息，你真的会感受到这种断网是多么彻底。我反反复复地听，心里想，他们说的每一部分内容都不应该被听到，哪怕是最基本的事情，比如人们每天都在做什么？断网不仅仅是逐行逐句的审查。它是对人们生活，有时甚至是死亡的全面抹除。
Here's what it took for people to get these messages out of Iran. They had to borrow or pay for a VPN or satellite connection, wait for it to actually work. Starlink connections in Iran keep getting shut down. They had to not get caught. Iranians have been imprisoned for speaking with foreign media. It sometimes took days to get these voice memos out of the country to us, often short messages, a minute at a time so the files were small enough to get through.
这就是人们将这些消息传出伊朗所付出的代价。他们不得不借用或购买 VPN 或卫星连接，等待它真正工作。伊朗的星链连接不断被切断。他们必须不能被抓住。伊朗人因为与外国媒体交谈而被监禁。有时需要几天时间才能将这些语音备忘录传出国外给我们，通常是短消息，一次一分钟，这样文件才足够小，能够发出来。
The messages came from a whole range of people, from different parts of Iran, different ages, professions, political views, and also different experiences. Every time I got one of these messages, I stopped what I was doing to listen all the way through. So I want to play them for you the way I heard them, one person after another. We have edited them but tried to leave them at a length where you can really hear what people have to say as they go about their day. I'm going to play the messages in four sections. We could call them acts.
这些消息来自各行各业的人，来自伊朗的不同地区，有着不同的年龄、职业、政治观点以及不同的经历。每当我收到一条这样的消息，我都会停下手头的工作，完整地听完。所以我想按照我听到它们的方式播放给你们听，一个接一个。我们对它们进行了剪辑，但尽量保持一定的长度，让你们在他们进行日常活动时，能真正听到他们想说的话。我将把这些消息分为四个部分播放。我们可以称之为“幕”。
So here we go, Act One, Both/And. In these first few messages, people talk about the dual experience of living both in a war and at the same time in an internet blackout, both dragging on and on, 63 days and counting as I record this now. First voice memo, Negin. She's in her early 40s and lives in Tehran with her boyfriend, Ameen.
那么开始了，第一幕，既是又是。在最初的几条消息中，人们谈论了同时生活在战争中和互联网断网中的双重经历，两者都在不断拖延，截至我录音时已经持续了63天。第一条语音备忘录来自 Negin。她40出头，和男友 Ameen 住在德黑兰。
After breakfast, I got ready to go to work, got into my car, and drove onto the highway. Then suddenly, Ameen called and said, Negin, they're bombing Tehran. That was pretty much my last call. All internet lines were suddenly cut off.
早餐后，我准备去上班，上了车，开上了高速公路。突然，Ameen 打来电话说，Negin，他们正在轰炸德黑兰。那几乎是我最后一个电话。所有的互联网线路突然全部切断。
This message and all the messages you're going to hear in the show is being read by an actor. To protect everyone's identity in this show, we've changed people's names, and we've asked Iranian and Iranian American actors outside of Iran to listen to the messages and then record what people said and how they said it onto their phones as voice memos. Some of the original messages were recorded in English. Most were translated from Persian. Once or twice, we've changed a small phrase for clarity. OK, back to Negin.
这条消息和节目中你将听到的所有消息都是由演员朗读的。为了保护节目中每个人的身份，我们更改了他们的名字，并邀请了伊朗境外的伊朗和伊朗裔美国演员听取这些消息，然后将人们说的话和语气录制在他们的手机上作为语音备忘录。有些原始消息是用英语录制的。大多数是从波斯语翻译过来的。偶尔，我们为了清晰起见修改了一个小短语。好了，回到 Negin。
And then they started hitting the East of Tehran, these strange, terrifying sounds. We were really not prepared for suddenly being in the middle of the highway and hearing sounds like that. Some people, they just parked their cars and they got out. And they were staring at the smoke. They didn't know what to do. Two, three people had gone and hidden in the bushes. It-- it was really strange.
然后他们开始轰炸德黑兰东部，那些奇怪、可怕的声音。我们真的没有准备好突然处于高速公路中间并听到那样的声音。有些人就把车停在路边下车了。他们盯着烟雾。他们不知道该做什么。有两三个人去躲进了灌木丛里。这……这真的很奇怪。
Then this delivery guy on a motorcycle passed by me. He had this Kurdish accent. My window was down, and I was completely terrified. He passed my car and said, Bibi finally came. And I was like, my god, nobody even knows how this war is going to end. Who cares about Bibi?
接着这个骑摩托车的送货员经过我身边。他带着库尔德口音。我的车窗是摇下来的，我感到非常恐惧。他经过我的车说，比比（Bibi）终于来了。而我心想，我的天，根本没人知道这场战争会如何结束。谁在乎比比？
I finally made it to Sohrevardi Street to go towards my mom's place. And I saw that they had closed all the schools, and they had called all the families to come pick up their children. Some of the mothers were clearly regular office workers. They were wearing their uniform of manteaus and trousers. And they were running on foot towards the schools because the streets were blocked. And everyone at the school was crying, begging for their children to come out faster.
我终于到了 Sohrevardi 街，准备往我妈住的地方走。我看到学校都关门了，通知所有家庭来接孩子。一些母亲显然是普通的上班族。她们穿着制服大衣和长裤。因为街道被封锁了，她们正步行奔向学校。学校里的每个人都在哭，乞求让他们的孩子快点出来。
And I went a little farther, and I got to this girls' high school. And I saw these girls come out. And they took off their headscarves and messed up their hair into the air. And they were chanting that, yes, now we are finally becoming free. [SLIGHT CHUCKLE]
我再往前走一点，到了这所女子高中。我看到这些女孩走出来。她们摘掉头巾，把头发拨乱。她们高呼着，是的，现在我们终于自由了。[轻笑]
Then a bomb hit somewhere nearby, and the sound was unbelievable. And at once, people just poured into the streets. And some people, clearly, they were gathering their things to leave Tehran.
然后附近发生了爆炸，声音大得令人难以置信。人群瞬间涌向街道。有些人显然正在收拾行李准备离开德黑兰。
Hello. Hope you're doing well. First, I apologize because, unfortunately, I've caught a cold these days. My voice is hoarse.
你好。希望你一切都好。首先，我道歉，因为不幸的是，这些天我感冒了。我的嗓子哑了。
This is Pooya. He's in his mid-30s. He owns a pizza shop in Tehran.
这是 Pooya。他30多岁。他在德黑兰开了一家披萨店。
But look, cutting the internet is a disaster. Our phones are constantly ringing. So-and-so, be careful. Such-and-such a place is being bombed. We worry about each other.
但是看，切断互联网是一场灾难。我们的电话响个不停。某某某，小心点。某某地方正在被轰炸。我们为彼此担心。
We wake up, try to have a normal day, which is not very normal. And we come to work, wait, reading the news. Some of us have the internet. Some don't. So part of the news is actually passed from person to person.
我们醒来，试图过正常的生活，但这并不正常。我们来到店里，等待，阅读新闻。有些人有网。有些人没有。所以部分新闻实际上是通过人传人的方式传播的。
When Tehran is attacked, I don't do anything special. I just sit where I am and go about my day, truthfully. There have been many times when I was cooking or doing whatever, and I just continued doing it because there was nothing I could do at that moment.
当德黑兰受到攻击时，我什么特别的事情都不做。说实话，我只是坐在原地，继续过我的一天。有很多次我正在做饭或做其他事，我只是继续做，因为当时我什么也做不了。
People come out now, eat, go to cafes. But economically, you can't just say conditions are bad. Conditions are almost on the verge of collapse. We've laid off nearly 70% of the staff or almost more. People still come to buy pizza, but much less often. Regarding the menu, some things have been limited, for example, the salads or the appetizers, like chicken and so on because it might not be economically viable for people to buy them right now. I took away the salads for a month. I'm bringing them back at the end of this week. But our beef bacon pizza is among the best sellers.
现在人们出来了，吃饭，去咖啡馆。但在经济上，你不能仅仅说情况很糟糕。情况几乎处于崩溃边缘。我们裁掉了近70%的员工。人们还是来买披萨，但频率少多了。关于菜单，有些东西受到限制，例如沙拉或开胃菜，像鸡肉等等，因为人们现在买这些可能不划算。我停售了沙拉一个月。这周结束时我会重新上架。但我们的牛肉培根披萨依然是最畅销的。
There are checkpoints everywhere in the streets. The atmosphere is really unsafe, very highly securitized. And I mean, we're very afraid of these checkpoints. We're really as afraid of the checkpoints as we are of bombs and missiles.
街头到处都是检查站。气氛非常不安全，高度戒备。我的意思是，我们非常害怕这些检查站。我们害怕检查站就像害怕炸弹和导弹一样。
Sarah is in her early 30s. She's talking here about checkpoints that have been set up all around the country by Iranian security forces, including the IRGC, the Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps.
Sarah 30出头。她在这里谈论的是伊朗安全部队，包括伊朗伊斯兰革命卫队（IRGC）在全国各地设置的检查站。
We know they check phones. We know they search photo galleries. We know they've arrested people we knew because of just something they found on their phone, like a photo or a call, or following a certain page or something like that. It's very terrifying. For a long time, I just didn't take my phone out with me at all. But for example, now that I've started taking it out, I just constantly erase everything and clear my phone of everything.
我们知道他们会检查手机。我们知道他们会搜索照片库。我们知道因为手机里发现的某些东西，比如照片、通话记录，或者关注了某个特定的页面之类，他们就逮捕了我们认识的人。这非常恐怖。很长一段时间里，我根本不敢把手机带出门。但比如现在我开始带了，我就不停地删除一切，清空手机里的所有东西。
Honestly, when things are outside of my control, I just start cleaning and tidying my house. I constantly clean everywhere in the house. I vacuum. I wash the dishes so the house is perfectly tidy. I cook. I start dusting, vacuuming, washing the bathroom, washing the kitchen, washing all the dishes in the sink. I started making jam, which I have never done before. I scrubbed the whole house with the thought that if there's no electricity or water, at least my house would stay clean for a few more days.
说实话，当事情超出我的控制时，我就开始打扫和整理房子。我不断地打扫屋子里的每一个角落。我吸尘。我洗碗，让房子变得完美整洁。我做饭。我开始掸灰、吸尘、刷厕所、洗厨房、洗水槽里的所有碗碟。我开始做果酱，这是我以前从没做过的事。我把整个屋子擦得干干净净，心想如果没电没水了，至少我的房子还能再保持几天清洁。
And then I took a shower. I blow-dried my hair. I mean, I know it's really stupid. Like, if they bomb your country's infrastructure, this might help you for, what, maybe two extra days? But it gave me a good feeling psychologically at least.
然后我洗了个澡。我吹干了头发。我是说，我知道这真的很蠢。就像，如果他们炸毁了你国家的基建设施，这可能帮你多撑个两天？但至少在心理上，这让我感觉好受了一些。
Next voice memo is from an emergency nurse, Silphia, in her late 20s. She lives in Isfahan, central Iran. Silphia talked about something other people mentioned too, trying to use the sort of substitute, very limited internal internet the Iranian authorities have created.
下一条语音备忘录来自一位急诊护士 Silphia，20多岁。她住在伊朗中部的伊斯法罕。Silphia 谈到了其他人也提到的事情，试图使用伊朗当局创建的那种替代性的、非常有限的内部互联网。
The national intranet only works inside Iran. It's its own system, tightly controlled and surveilled. There are apps for messaging, texting inside the country, banking services. There's an Iranian search engine called Torob. And sometimes some international sites can be accessed through the internal intranet, but others can't. Silphia had a day off work and was testing out what she could and could not do on the internal system.
国家内网仅在伊朗境内工作。它有自己的系统，受到严格控制和监视。国内有用于发送消息、发短信的应用程序，还有银行服务。有一个名为 Torob 的伊朗搜索引擎。有时可以通过内部网访问一些国际网站，但其他的则不行。Silphia 那天休息，正在测试她在内部系统上能做什么和不能做什么。
I wanted to buy cologne, so I ordered that online. And I had no problem with the payment. Some sites that you used to connect to directly through Torob, they don't open now. And so I don't know why some open, some don't. I don't know what the problem is or what difference there is.
我想买古龙水，所以就在网上订购了。付款没问题。一些以前可以直接通过 Torob 连接的网站，现在打不开了。所以我不知道为什么有的能开，有的不能。我不知道问题出在哪里，或者有什么区别。
Now I almost feel a bit illiterate because before, whenever something came to my mind that I didn't know, I would quickly google it. And I spent so much time every day talking to ChatGPT. I would consult it about everything I wanted to do. But now I can't do any of those things because basically, my phone has just turned into a tool for calling, texting, taking photos, things like that. That's it.
现在我几乎觉得自己有点文盲了，因为以前只要想到什么不知道的东西，我就会立刻谷歌一下。我每天花很多时间跟 ChatGPT 聊天。我想做什么都会去咨询它。但现在我做不了任何这些事情了，因为基本上，我的手机已经变成了一个只能打电话、发短信、拍照之类东西的工具。仅此而已。
There is an app they've provided as a replacement for Google called Zarebin, but I haven't been able to get anything decent out of it so far. What you search for has to be very common and simple, like searching for the name of a medicine, for example. And even then, it doesn't show all the references. It brings up some very simple Iranian references and basic explanation. Otherwise, it doesn't give you a proper answer for anything else. I even wanted to find a number for a fast food place through it so I could call them, but it wouldn't bring it up for me. That's how ridiculous it is.
他们提供了一个叫 Zarebin 的应用程序来代替谷歌，但我至今还没能从中得到任何有用的东西。你搜索的内容必须是非常常见且简单的，比如搜索药品名称。即便如此，它也不会显示所有的参考资料。它只会出现一些非常简单的伊朗参考资料和基本解释。除此之外，它给不了你任何其他东西的正确答案。我甚至想通过它找一家快餐店的电话号码好订餐，但它根本搜不到。就是这么荒谬。
Okay, now I want to play a different group of messages for you. Act Two, The Blackout Before This One. From an American perspective, we went to war with Iran. That's what's happening there. That's where the story begins. But this war for Iranians landed in the middle of an ongoing story about what's been happening inside the country. And these next two people who sent voice memos, they had a role in that story.
好了，现在我想给你们播放另一组消息。第二幕，上一次断网。从美国的角度来看，我们和伊朗开战了。这就是那里正在发生的事情。故事就是从那里开始的。但对于伊朗人来说，这场战争发生在关于国内一直发生的事情的持续故事之中。接下来发送语音备忘录的两个人，他们在那个故事中扮演了角色。
There have been regular large protests against the Iranian regime for years in Iran. And right before the war, massive demonstrations erupted around the entire country. People took to the streets demanding the end of the regime, which has been in power in Iran for almost 50 years. The protests went on for weeks. And then Iranian authorities put the country into a full communications blackout. It started on January 8. Over the next few days, during the blackout, security forces massacred people all across the country. They killed thousands, possibly tens of thousands, of their own citizens.
多年来，伊朗一直有针对伊朗政权的定期大规模抗议活动。就在战争爆发前，全国爆发了大规模示威游行。人们走上街头要求结束这个在伊朗掌权近50年的政权。抗议持续了数周。然后伊朗当局让全国陷入了全面的通信中断。它始于1月8日。在接下来的几天里，在断网期间，安全部队在全国范围内对民众进行了屠杀。他们杀害了数千人，甚至可能是数万人自己的公民。
They did this at a moment when there was no way for people to tell anyone, to post photos or videos, or to warn their friends, or call international reporters, or even reach family outside of the country. We still don't know the scale of the killing. Human rights groups have been trying to document as many deaths as they can. In a blackout, you can die without being counted.
他们是在这样一个时刻这样做的：人们无法告诉任何人，无法发布照片或视频，无法提醒朋友，无法致电国际记者，甚至无法联系国外的家人。我们至今不知道杀戮的规模。人权组织一直在尽力记录他们能记录的所有死亡。在断网状态下，你死了也可能无人知晓。
The two reporters who collected voice memos for today's show, Roxana Saberi and Fatemeh Jamalpour, also managed to get messages out during the last blackout. Dozens of people inside Iran found ways to send them rare firsthand accounts-- images, videos, medical records-- that suggested that the IRGC and other security forces shot protesters at close range, targeting their heads and chests, their eyes.
为今天节目收集语音备忘录的两位记者 Roxana Saberi 和 Fatemeh Jamalpour，在上次断网期间也成功获取了消息。伊朗境内数十人找到了发送罕见第一手资料的方法——图片、视频、医疗记录——这些资料表明，革命卫队和其他安全部队近距离射杀了抗议者，瞄准他们的头部、胸部和眼睛。
The protests and killings in January haunted some of the voice memos we got, even as people try to continue living, going about their normal routines. Amin is in his 20s. He's a professional bodybuilder in Tehran. He joined the protests. One of his friends was shot and killed while protesting, Mehdi Zatparvar. He was a well-known champion bodybuilder.
1月份的抗议和杀戮阴影笼罩着我们收到的一些语音备忘录，尽管人们试图继续生活，恢复正常的日常活动。Amin 20多岁。他是德黑兰的一名职业健美运动员。他参加了抗议活动。他的一位朋友 Mehdi Zatparvar 在抗议时被枪杀。他是一位著名的健美冠军。
I've been on a special diet since January. I wanted to compete back then, but I didn't. I canceled it out of respect for those who were killed, out of respect for Mr. Zatparvar. After that, competitions were canceled altogether. And gradually, I just kept my diet because I saw I had nothing else to do.
从一月起，我就一直控制饮食。那时我想参加比赛，但我没去。出于对那些被杀害的人的尊重，出于对 Zatparvar 先生的尊重。那之后，比赛全部取消了。渐渐地，我只是维持着我的饮食，因为我发现我无事可做。
I usually wake up at 4:45, and I do my cardio from 5:00 to 6:00. I get by with seven or eight meals a day, even though prices have skyrocketed and my savings are completely gone, but I am still keeping at it anyway.
我通常在4:45醒来，5:00到6:00做有氧运动。我一天吃七八顿饭维持体力，尽管价格飞涨，我的积蓄也花光了，但我还是坚持着。
I generally don't follow the news anymore, neither Iranian nor foreign news. Iran International says one thing, and Iran state TV says another. So I simply don't get my mind involved with the news anymore. Unless, for example, Trump tweets. Whatever he posts, we basically assume the opposite because he either does exactly what he says or the exact opposite.
我一般不再关注新闻了，无论是伊朗新闻还是外国新闻。伊朗国际电视台说一套，伊朗国家电视台说另一套。所以我干脆不再让新闻占据我的大脑了。除非比如特朗普发推特。无论他发什么，我们基本上都假设是反着来的，因为他要么完全按他说的做，要么完全背道而驰。
Right in front of me is a checkpoint, and I am passing through it. The IRGC is completely controlling everything with its own full supervision. Recently, I've been recording videos as motivation for those who think they just need to sit at home during the war. I really want to try to convince them, through exercise, they can live in a way that at least keeps their vibes high.
我面前就是一个检查站，我正在通过。革命卫队在完全监督下控制着一切。最近，我一直录制视频，作为那些认为战争期间只需要待在家里的人的激励。我真的想通过锻炼说服他们，他们可以以一种至少能保持高昂情绪的方式生活。
Anushirvan is a doctor in the north of Iran. He's young, in his mid 20s. He spent January treating hundreds of wounded protesters, some of them shot with military-grade weapons, sometimes at close distance, sometimes in the head. And while he was treating people, plainclothes security agents roamed the hospital. So if someone needed an X-ray, Anushirvan and his colleagues would personally escort them to radiology so they wouldn't be detained. They showed people how to leave out the back door of the hospital.
Anushirvan 是伊朗北部的一名医生。他很年轻，20多岁。他在一月里治疗了数百名受伤的抗议者，其中一些人被军用武器击中，有时是近距离，有时被击中头部。当他治疗伤者时，便衣安全人员就在医院里徘徊。如果有人需要拍X光片，Anushirvan 和他的同事会亲自陪同他们去放射科，以免被拘留。他们教人们如何从医院后门离开。
As he worked, Anushirvan began saving X-rays and photographs and notes in a panic that the regime, through its blackout, would succeed in hiding what it had done. In a lot of ways, it has. And now, in another blackout, an endless blackout, Anushirvan is just still doing his job, getting through each day.
工作时，Anushirvan 开始恐慌性地保存X光片、照片和记录，生怕政权通过断网成功掩盖其所作所为。在很多方面，它确实做到了。而现在，在又一次断网中，无休止的断网中，Anushirvan 只是继续做他的工作，度过每一天。
After eating a very sad excuse for a breakfast, I fed my cats, which I had adopted after the events of January due to my friend's recommendation to have a companion in those times. I believe it helped. Very interesting creatures, cats are. I dressed up and called for, you could say, an Iranian version of an Uber to the hospital, went downstairs.
吃了一顿非常悲惨的早餐后，我喂了我的猫，这是我在一月份事件后，因为朋友建议在那些时刻找个伴而领养的。我相信这有帮助。猫真是非常有趣的生物。我穿好衣服，叫了一辆伊朗版的“优步”去医院，下了楼。
And looking at the car, it was barely functioning and being held together. And the driver had a very, say, stereotypical type of beard. And my suspicions were confirmed when I sat in the car and saw two stickers of Soleimani and Khamenei on the dashboard of his car, not exactly the two faces I want to see that early in the day, but you know.
看着那辆车，它几乎快报废了，全靠勉强拼凑。司机的胡子有一种非常刻板印象的风格。当我坐在车里看到仪表盘上有两张苏莱曼尼和哈梅内伊的贴纸时，我的怀疑得到了证实，这一大早确实不是我想看到的两张脸，但你知道的。
So he drove me to the hospital and saw a white lab coat in my bag and asked if I was a doctor. And then he said, "may God give you strength, Doctor." Of course, had the situation been a lot different, him, or at least, the men of his type, would have beaten me to death. But I thanked him properly still. I'm not saying anyone who believes in the regime would kill you in the streets for protesting them, but it could be an unignited dynamite.
他开车送我到医院，看到我包里的白大褂，问我是不是医生。然后他说，“愿上帝赐予你力量，医生。”当然，如果情况大不相同，他，或者至少是那种类型的人，会把我活活打死。但我还是礼貌地向他表示了感谢。我不是说任何相信政权的人都会在街上因为抗议而杀人，但它可能就像未点燃的炸药。
So I reached the hospital. And it was a fairly nice shift. Not a lot of critical patients, fortunately. So I could spend some time in the pavilion, watching my new favorite show, The Walking Dead. It's my favorite show because basically I cannot tolerate anything else because at least in The Walking Dead, the things are objectively worse for the people there than it is for the Iranians right now. That is the only thing I can tolerate. I really like the show. Daryl is my favorite character. I sure hope nothing bad happens to him. And, well, let's see how poorly this ages.
我到了医院。那是一个相当不错的班次。幸运的是，没有太多重症患者。所以我可以在休息室待一会儿，看我最喜欢的新剧《行尸走肉》。这是我最喜欢的剧，因为基本上我无法容忍其他任何东西，因为至少在《行尸走肉》里，人们的情况客观上比现在的伊朗人还要糟糕。这是我唯一能忍受的东西。我真的很喜欢这部剧。达里尔（Daryl）是我最喜欢的角色。我真希望他别出事。嗯，让我们看看这番话未来会显得多么打脸。
One of my patients was an 11-year-old girl coming in with a chief complaint of extreme headache in front of her head. It was nothing too serious. I asked if she's undergone any stress recently, kind of an obvious question these days, but she was a child. I asked the parents if she had any access to any of the news of the war, and they confirmed it, which sounds like very poor parenting to me.
我的一位患者是个11岁的小女孩，主诉是额头剧烈头痛。这没什么大碍。我问她最近是否承受了任何压力，这在这些天听起来是个显而易见的问题，但她只是个孩子。我问家长她是否接触过任何战争新闻，他们确认了，这在我看来是非常糟糕的育儿方式。
So after making sure the hospital was stabilized, me and two of my friends went to the park near the hospital to smoke cigarettes. I had never smoked any cigarettes up until, like, two months ago. My very first cigarette was upon hearing the news, the confirmation of Khamenei being killed. And I'm really glad I waited that long because now every time I do it, I'm reminded of that night, as it was one of the best nights of my life.
确认医院平稳后，我和两个朋友去了医院附近的公园抽烟。直到两个月前，我从没抽过烟。我的第一根烟是在听到新闻确认哈梅内伊被杀的那一刻抽的。我很高兴我等了那么久，因为现在每次我抽烟，我都会想起那个晚上，那是我一生中最美好的夜晚之一。
Anushirvan spent more than half of his monthly salary on a VPN. Then he got online finally and was devastated. He saw some of what was being said about Iran in the wider world.
Anushirvan 花了月薪的一半购买 VPN。然后他终于连上了网，感到崩溃。他看到了外部世界对伊朗的一些言论。
By far, the most difficult moments for me during the blackouts were times like this, where I could barely connect with the VPNs, only to see people on social media falling for the regime propaganda. And I'm not talking about Iranians. These are people living in free countries, and that is incredibly depressing to see.
断网期间对我来说，最困难的时刻莫过于此，我好不容易连上 VPN，却看到社交媒体上的人们轻信政权的宣传。我指的不是伊朗人。这是生活在自由国家的人，这看起来极其令人沮丧。
I've seen charlatans actually denying the January massacre, in which dozens of thousands of people were killed, and whitewashing the Islamic Republic all the way through, just because they disagree with this war, or Trump, or the US foreign policy as a whole, outright denying the January massacre and saying there is no evidence for that, the massacre which I saw happen and the evidence I collected.
我见过骗子竟然否认一月份的屠杀，在那场屠杀中，数以万计的人被杀害，他们全程粉饰伊斯兰共和国，仅仅因为他们不同意这场战争，或者特朗普，或者美国的整体外交政策，断然否认一月份的屠杀，说没有任何证据，我亲眼目睹了那场屠杀，并收集了证据。
There is no excuse in that. They have zero right to do that. And for the first time ever, I truly understand why, for example, Holocaust denial is and should always be a crime, as you can't imagine the pain of seeing such privileged people denying your suffering.
这根本没借口。他们没有任何权利这样做。这是我有生以来第一次真正理解为什么例如大屠杀否认论应该永远是一种犯罪，因为你无法想象看到那些拥有特权的人否认你的痛苦是多么心痛。
Coming up, more from inside Iran, including that day President Trump said "a whole civilization will die tonight." What was that like? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
稍后，更多来自伊朗内部的消息，包括特朗普总统说“今晚整个文明将消失”的那一天。那是种什么感觉？一分钟后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, we hear from people inside Iran, people who are living through a war and an internet blackout that the UN Human Rights Office has said is, quote, "one of the longest and most severe shutdowns ever recorded globally." We're hearing what that's like from Iranians who managed to get voice memos out of the country, in spite of it being difficult and dangerous to send them.
这里是《美国生活》。我是 Chana Joffe-Walt，代班 Ira Glass。今天节目，我们听取了来自伊朗内部的声音，这些人正经历着战争和互联网断网，联合国人权办公室称这是，“全球记录在案最长、最严重的断网之一”。我们正在从成功将语音备忘录传出国的伊朗人那里听到这是一种什么样的体验，尽管发送过程既困难又危险。
Act Three, Neighbors, Friends, and Lovers. Iran's a big country. It had deep divisions before the war. There were massive protests against the Islamic Republic and a brutal crackdown just over a month before America and Israel attacked. And in the messages we got, responses to the war were all over the map.
第三幕，邻居、朋友和恋人。伊朗是个大国。战前它就存在严重的裂痕。就在美国和以色列袭击前一个多月，伊朗发生了大规模的针对伊斯兰共和国的抗议活动，并遭到残酷镇压。在我们收到的消息中，对战争的反应五花八门。
All the people are happy. I'm telling you. Say thanks, President Trump. Thanks, Netanyahu. And they pray to God that Bibi and Daddy-- [LAUGHS] I mean Donald Trump-- they can-- they may help. Because many people, as a joke, and they say Daddy to him. [LAUGHS]
所有人都在欢呼。我告诉你。替我们说声谢谢，特朗普总统。谢谢你，内塔尼亚胡。他们向上帝祈祷，希望比比和爸爸——[笑]我是说唐纳德·特朗普——他们能……他们可能会帮忙。因为许多人开玩笑地叫他“爸爸”。[笑]
Vahid owns a small business. He's in his mid-40s, lives on the outskirts of a big city in northern Iran. He despises the Islamic regime, wants a secular democracy in Iran. The protests and massacres in January convinced Vahid that change will never happen without outside help.
Vahid 经营一家小企业。他40多岁，住在伊朗北部大城市郊区。他鄙视伊斯兰政权，渴望在伊朗建立世俗民主。一月份的抗议和屠杀让 Vahid 坚信，没有外部帮助，改变永远不会发生。
Everyone is preparing themselves for the moment that President Trump and Bibi declare that the situation is such that people can come out. They will flood to regime to take them over. And they all expect to have a new life after this regime.
每个人都在为特朗普总统和比比宣布局势允许人们走上街头的那一刻做准备。他们会涌向政权将他们取而代之。他们都期待在政权倒台后过上新生活。
The internet is not stable. The moment you send me a message until now, it took four hours and 36 minutes arrived to me. The speed is very slow.
互联网不稳定。你发给我的消息，到现在才收到，用了4小时36分钟。网速非常慢。
And you should know the Islamic Republic and their fear-- and this is not just my opinion. Everybody thinks the same thing-- is not that internet would be used against them in war. They are afraid that internet will become a tool to help protesters to get together and create an internal revolution. And that's what they are afraid of. That's why they shut down the internet.
而且你应该知道，伊斯兰共和国和他们的恐惧——这不仅仅是我的观点，大家都有同样的看法——不是担心互联网在战争中被用来对付他们。他们担心的是互联网会成为帮助抗议者聚集并引发内部革命的工具。这就是他们所害怕的。这就是他们关闭互联网的原因。
I don't remember exactly if I told you that I have a family member, he has a bad autoimmune disorder. He was worried. We were watching Iran International by satellite. And he told me, what will come up if President Trump is going to do shutdown of electricity and all of the infrastructures? What would happen to the country?
我不记得是否告诉过你，我有个家人患有严重的自身免疫性疾病。他很担心。我们通过卫星收看伊朗国际电视台。他问我，如果特朗普总统要切断电力和所有基础设施，会发生什么？这个国家会怎么样？
And he was worried. He was worried about all the people like him that they have bad health issues and they need full care. I said to him, our situation is like that. We want to have freedom and going far away from this government, this IRGC. And it would be needed to pay by something.
他很担心。他担心所有像他一样有严重健康问题需要全面护理的人。我对他说，我们的情况就是这样。我们想要自由，摆脱这个政府，这个革命卫队。这需要付出代价。
This is the cost of freedom. And that's a shame. But I have a good feeling that this is the last second of this government.
这就是自由的代价。真遗憾。但我有一种预感，这是这个政府的最后时刻了。
Well, the conversations vary, but everyone talks to each other with a certain caution, meaning, in a way, they size each other up so they don't get challenged.
嗯，谈话内容各异，但每个人在交谈时都带有一种谨慎，也就是说，某种程度上，他们是在评估对方，以免遭到质疑。
Omid works at a film studio in Tehran. He makes all sorts of content. He worked on a candid camera show recently. Some of the work his team has done is for state TV. He's sympathetic to the regime, including the blackouts policy. The Iranian foreign minister, Abbas Araghchi, said the internet is shut off in Iran for security reasons while the country is under attack. That idea makes sense to Omid. At work, Omid is a manager.
Omid 在德黑兰的一家电影工作室工作。他制作各种内容。他最近参与了一个隐藏摄像机节目的制作。他团队的一些工作是为国家电视台服务的。他同情政权，包括断网政策。伊朗外交部长阿巴斯·阿拉格齐（Abbas Araghchi）表示，由于国家正处于攻击之下，伊朗关闭互联网是出于安全考虑。这个想法对 Omid 来说是有道理的。在工作中，Omid 是一位经理。
Out of the 24 or 25 people who work under me, one or two of them are very left leaning and opposed. For example, regarding the news of the martyrdom or death of Khamenei, who was ultimately the leader of the country-- look, I had my criticisms of his performance. But regardless, it's a war. And when you lose your leader in a war, ultimately, you're shocked, sad, and confused. But one of the guys was happy. And it was like, if he wasn't embarrassed in front of me, he would have handed out sweets.
在我手下工作的24或25人中，有一两个非常左倾，持反对意见。例如，关于哈梅内伊的殉难或去世的消息，他毕竟是国家的领袖——听着，我对他的表现是有批评的。但无论如何，这是战争。当你在战争中失去领导人时，最终你会感到震惊、悲伤和困惑。但其中一个人很高兴。就好像，如果不是在我面前不好意思，他可能都要分发糖果了。
I see the IRGC, the army, the police force, which are operating under a more or less unified command and are serving the country. They stood, fought, were killed, were martyred, were assassinated. They could have just left, but thank god they stayed. The Americans should be satisfied with Venezuela and their own oil in-- I don't know-- Saudi Arabia. They should stop their wickedness.
我看到革命卫队、军队、警察部队，在或多或少统一的指挥下运作，服务于国家。他们站出来，战斗，牺牲，殉难，被暗杀。他们本可以离开，但谢天谢地，他们留下来了。美国人应该满足于委内瑞拉和他们自己的石油，我不知道，沙特阿拉伯。他们应该停止他们的邪恶行径。
Regarding the internet blackout, I was forced to use a VPN. But the point is that we're in a war, and I think being connected could have perhaps caused more damage. Thankfully, we didn't have any unrest or clashes, I mean, at least not that I'm aware of. Or, I don't know, those common cyber attacks hitting those different networks, like banking network, the network of-- I don't know-- digital currency exchanges.
关于互联网断网，我被迫使用了 VPN。但重点是我们正处于战争状态，我认为保持连接可能反而会造成更大的损害。幸运的是，我们没有发生任何动乱或冲突，我的意思是，至少我没听说。或者，我不知道，那些常见的攻击不同网络的网络攻击，比如银行网络、数字货币交易网络。
Most of the people around me have come to terms with the fact that right now, the conditions are wartime. And it's necessary, for example, to have certain limitations and control.
我周围的大多数人都已经接受了现状，即现在是战时状态。有某种限制和控制是必要的。
At night in Tehran and throughout a lot of the country, regime supporters have been gathering in squares to chant in support of the Islamic Republic and wave flags.
在德黑兰的夜晚，以及全国各地的许多地方，政权支持者一直在聚集在广场上，高呼支持伊斯兰共和国的口号，挥舞旗帜。
Near our office, there's a street running north to south that's uphill. I mean, it's quite uphill. I see a lady whose husband is in a wheelchair. And she's around 45, maybe 50 years old. And this lady and her husband come this way every night. They go to the Second Square of Tehranpars and chant.
我们办公室附近，有一条向南延伸的上坡路。我的意思是，真的很陡。我看到一位女士，她的丈夫坐在轮椅上。她大约45岁，或者50岁。这位女士和她的丈夫每晚都会走这条路。他们去德黑兰帕斯（Tehranpars）的第二广场高喊口号。
And I sometimes come to the window to smoke a cigarette and I've seen them. They go by at 8:30 or a quarter to 9:00. And then they return around, like, 10:30, 11:00. And this poor woman sometimes has a hard time on the way back alone because the man is a bit heavy. And sometimes I've seen people go up an alley to help them get home.
我有时会走到窗边抽烟，见到过他们。他们大约8:30或8:45经过。然后大约10:30、11:00回来。这个可怜的女人在回来的路上有时很艰难，因为那个男人有点重。有时我看到人们走上小巷去帮助他们回家。
The fact that a group of people are so patriotic and so dedicated that every night-- every night, whether it's raining, it's cold, it's hot-- they get up and come to the city squares and participate in gatherings, chant, and so on, it's really heartwarming, and it's very fascinating. I really wish you were here to see it up close.
一群人如此爱国、如此忠诚，以至于每晚——无论是下雨、天冷还是天热——他们都起床来到城市广场参加集会，呼喊口号，这真的很暖心，也很令人着迷。我真希望你在这里近距离看看。
There have been, every night, protests from the government supporters for almost one month. Whenever I'm out at almost 9:00 PM, I see them. Oh my goodness, not again.
几乎一个月以来，政府支持者每晚都有抗议活动。每当我在晚上9点左右出门，我都能见到他们。哦天呐，又来了。
Mahrou is in her 30s, lives outside Tehran. She works as an English tutor online. But there's not a lot of that work these days, so she's been taking on extra hours at her dad's pharmacy. She's there 'til nighttime. She sees the rallies on her way home.
Mahrou 30多岁，住在德黑兰郊外。她是一名在线英语家教。但这些天工作不多，所以她在她父亲的药店加了班。她一直待到深夜。她在回家的路上会看到这些集会。
The men chant repeated slogans in favor of the regime. They declare that they're ready to be martyrs of Islam and the Islamic Republic. Once I even saw a few of them wearing shrouds to prove they're ready to die for their cause. When I go to bed, I think about Reza. I immediately burst into tears. Reza is the guy I've been in love with lately who turned out to be a religious fanatic. I knew he wasn't my match, but I couldn't help but to love him.
男人们反复高呼支持政权的口号。他们宣称他们已准备好成为伊斯兰和伊斯兰共和国的烈士。有一次我甚至看到他们中几个人穿着寿衣，证明他们准备为事业而死。当我上床睡觉时，我想到 Reza。我立刻泪流满面。Reza 是我最近爱上的一个男人，结果竟然是个宗教狂热分子。我知道我们不合适，但我控制不住爱上他。
Reza and I met at my dad's pharmacy. He's a pharmacist. We used to work different shifts. All I knew about him at first was through my brother, my brother's high opinion of him. I remember a winter evening that I went to the pharmacy to give my brother something. Being in my 30s, I'm mature enough not to believe in love at first sight. But at the very first moment I saw him, he captured my attention.
我和 Reza 是在我爸的药店认识的。他是个药剂师。我们以前上不同的班。起初我对他的一切了解都是通过我兄弟，我兄弟对他评价很高。我记得一个冬天的晚上，我去药店给我兄弟送东西。30多岁的我，成熟到不相信一见钟情了。但在看到他的第一眼，他就吸引了我的注意。
Gradually, I tried to change my work shift for two days of the week in order to meet him more. He was always well groomed and obviously picky in the way he dressed. He looked so mild-mannered, kind, always ready to help the people around him. We started texting each other. At first, it was only about work, but we gradually switched to other personal issues. At first, he was so cautious because he was our employee. But little by little, he stepped forward.
渐渐地，我试着把工作班次换成一周两天，为了多见他。他总是衣着整洁，显然很讲究。他看起来非常温和、善良，总是乐于帮助周围的人。我们开始互发短信。起初只是关于工作，但渐渐地转向了其他个人问题。一开始他很谨慎，因为他是我们的员工。但一点一点地，他迈出了那一步。
To be honest with you, I already knew that he was a religious guy, at least, more than me. But I didn't expect him to be a religious fanatic with rigid opinions about Islam and the regime. The first time that I was shocked at his perspectives was during the 12-Day War with Israel, around nine months ago. He believed that Iran should not reach an agreement or stop the war because doing so will make us lose our dignity.
老实说，我早就知道他是个宗教信徒，至少比我虔诚。但我没料到他会是一个对伊斯兰教和政权持强硬观点的宗教狂热分子。第一次被他的观点震惊是在大约九个月前，针对以色列的12天战争期间。他认为伊朗不应该达成协议或停止战争，因为那样会让我们失去尊严。
I was like, what are you talking about? Iranian people are being killed. To me, dignity was an abstract concept. People's lives was something that mattered to me. Since then, I chose not to talk about politics with him. Honestly, I knew that trying to be dismissive of politics and religion was not the solution, but unfortunately, I was deeply involved with him.
我当时就想，你在说什么？伊朗人民正在被杀害。对我来说，尊严是一个抽象概念。人们的生命才是我关心的。从那时起，我选择不和他谈论政治。说实话，我知道试图回避政治和宗教并不是解决办法，但遗憾的是，我太深陷于这段感情了。
Few days before the war, he left our pharmacy because he was about to establish his own. Since then, we've met a couple times. The last time we met, almost 20 days ago, he mentioned that he agreed with the idea of digital blackout for now, because in this way, the government can be in control of the enemy's propaganda against the Islamic Republic. I was like, how dare you say so? People are losing their jobs because of this blackout, and you're talking about your idea of propaganda? I think this war made me far more realistic about Reza and my love for him. This war was an accelerator. It made our relationship go downhill faster.
战争爆发前几天，他离开了我们的药店，因为他要建立自己的药店。从那之后，我们见过几次。我们最后一次见面大约是20天前，他提到他赞成目前的数字断网，因为通过这种方式，政府可以控制敌人对伊斯兰共和国的宣传。我心想，你怎么敢这么说？人们因为断网失业了，你却在谈论你的宣传理念？我认为这场战争让我对 Reza 和我们之间的爱变得更加现实了。这场战争是一个加速器。它让我们的关系向下坡路走得更快了。
Act Four, Now What? Every time I hear President Trump declare what Iranians want, or what they should do, or what he thinks should come next, and every time he tosses off a threat, I want to know, what is it like for Iranians to hear that? Are they hearing that? Another thing the blackout has erased or stifled.
第四幕，现在怎么办？每当我听到特朗普总统宣称伊朗人想要什么，或者他们应该做什么，或者他认为接下来应该发生什么，每当他随意抛出威胁时，我都很想知道，伊朗人听到这些是什么感觉？他们听到了吗？这是断网抹除或扼杀的另一件事。
For instance, what was it like for Iranians on the day that happened only a few weeks ago, when President Trump posted on Truth Social about Iran, quote, "A whole civilization will die tonight, never to be brought back again. I don't want that to happen, but it probably will."
例如，就在几周前，当特朗普总统在 Truth Social 上发布关于伊朗的消息时，伊朗人是什么感觉？“今晚整个文明将消失，永不复返。我不想发生这种情况，但很可能会发生。”
We got several voice memos about that day. I'm going to play one from the doctor, Anushirvan, who treated patients during the January massacre, then Sarah in Tehran, the woman who'd been blow-drying her hair in case US strikes knocked out Iranian power plants. Trump had set a deadline for Iran that day to open the Strait of Hormuz. The deadline was evening in the US, 3:30 in the morning in Iran.
我们收到了几条关于那天的语音备忘录。我要播放一条来自医生 Anushirvan 的录音，他在一月份的屠杀中治疗过伤者，然后是德黑兰的 Sarah，那个为了防止美国袭击摧毁伊朗电厂而吹干头发的女人。特朗普那天给伊朗设定了开放霍尔木兹海峡的最后期限。截止时间是美国傍晚，伊朗凌晨3:30。
Part of me didn't really want to take Trump seriously, but he is the president of the most powerful country in the world, so there is that. In Iran's time, it would be around 3 and 1/2 AM, if I'm not mistaken. I had charged my phone, my laptop, my portable power bank, not that they were going to last too long anyway, and had my essentials ready to go in case of emergency or if I decided to move back to my hometown, since being so high up in my current apartment, no electricity would also mean no water pump, not to mention no elevator.
我内心一部分并不想把特朗普当真，但他是世界上最强大国家的总统，所以情况确实如此。按伊朗时间算，应该在凌晨3点半左右，如果我没记错的话。我充好了手机、笔记本电脑和便携充电宝，虽然它们也坚持不了多久，我准备好了必需品，以防紧急情况发生，或者我决定搬回老家，因为如果电网断了，住在公寓楼高处意味着没有水泵，更不用说没有电梯了。
I took a shower. And I think it was around 2:00 AM when I decided to leave it up to fate and sleep and wake up to either the unthinkable or to a war-torn country. And, yes, by unthinkable, I mean the ceasefire, as I had no idea what it would look like. I woke up automatically around 5:00 AM, grabbed my phone, and saw my dad's text notification that there was a ceasefire. I stared into the message a good couple minutes, stone faced, before going back to sleep.
我洗了个澡。我想大概是凌晨2点，我决定顺其自然，睡觉，醒来时要么面对不可想象的事情，要么面对一个战火纷飞的国家。是的，所谓的“不可想象”，我指的是停火，因为我不知道那会是什么样子。我自动在凌晨5点左右醒来，抓起手机，看到我爸爸发来的短信通知，说已经停火了。我盯着消息看了好几分钟，面无表情，然后继续睡觉。
To make all the damages caused by the war worth it, we would have to have a regime change. But now it looks like we just got the shorter stick on both ends. It brought nothing but more death and misery, not to mention it further entrenched the regime. This was one of the dumbest wars in history, to be honest.
要让战争造成的损失变得值得，我们必须实现政权更迭。但现在看来，我们两头都没落着好。它没带来什么，只带来了更多的死亡和痛苦，更不用说它进一步巩固了政权。老实说，这是历史上最愚蠢的战争之一。
Last night, I was awake until maybe 12:30 or so. And there's a hallway in our house that has no windows around it, no glass. So that's where we sleep at night when they bomb. We go there to take shelter. And I was trying to sleep, but I was constantly checking the internet to see what was happening, where they were saying what. And I just had a feeling that there was going to be a ceasefire.
昨晚，我一直醒着直到12:30左右。我们家有一条走廊，周围没有窗户，没有玻璃。所以轰炸时我们晚上就睡在那里。我们去那里避难。我试着睡觉，但我一直在检查互联网，看看发生了什么，他们在说什么。我当时就有种预感，会有停火。
So I couldn't sleep. But I finally did fall asleep. And then the next morning, my partner told me that there had been a ceasefire. And to be honest, my feeling when I read that news was just very, very, very full of rage, especially the things that I read. And I mean, I honestly don't know how much of it is propaganda and how much of it is reality. But the things I read, that Iran is even earning money from The Strait of Hormuz during the ceasefire. Because we, the people of Iran, know that that money earned from there is not going to be spent on us. So we're just thinking that, well, we're just going to have a richer IRGC, and they're going to commit crimes even more easily. And I'm really, really afraid for the kids who are in prison, the kids who received death sentences, because I know they're going to be persecuted terribly. Executions are going to increase.
所以我睡不着。但我最终还是睡着了。第二天早上，我的伴侣告诉我停火了。说实话，当我读到那个消息时，我的感觉充满了愤怒，尤其是当我读到那些东西的时候。我是说，老实说我不知道其中有多少是宣传，有多少是现实。但我读到的是，伊朗甚至在停火期间还在从霍尔木兹海峡赚钱。因为我们伊朗人民知道，从那里赚的钱不会花在我们身上。所以我们只是在想，好吧，我们要面对的是一个更有钱的革命卫队，他们可以更容易地犯罪。我真的、真的为那些在监狱里的孩子们感到害怕，那些被判死刑的孩子，因为我知道他们会遭受极其可怕的迫害。处决人数会增加。
I think we're going to have even more severe crackdowns. Probably any kind of social movement of any form, which I honestly find unlikely after the January massacres, but they'll face an even greater massacre. I feel like we're the main losers of this war, the people of Iran. Because practically nothing has changed.
我想我们会遭受更严重的镇压。可能任何形式的社会运动，说实话在一月份的大屠杀之后我发现这不太可能，但他们将面临更大规模的屠杀。我觉得我们是这场战争的主要输家，我们伊朗人民。因为实际上什么都没改变。
One voice memo was short and to the point, from Khabat, a carpenter. He's Kurdish, an ethnic minority in Iran, living in the western part of the country.
有一条语音备忘录既简短又直截了当，来自木匠 Khabat。他是库尔德人，伊朗的一个少数民族，住在该国西部。
People are really frustrated with Trump. Wasn't he supposed to keep the pressure on until the regime surrendered? Why is he going to negotiate now? He was supposed to finish them off, not talk to them.
人们对特朗普非常沮丧。他不是应该保持压力直到政权投降吗？他为什么要谈判？他应该结束他们，而不是和他们谈。
One last person-- Arta. He runs a tech company in Isfahan. Arta's voice memos came in last. I listened after hearing all of the others. And it helped me understand something I hadn't before about where things might be headed in Iran. Arta was deeply unsettled by people around him who were furious that President Trump did not follow through on his threats, especially a promise Trump made on social media to bomb Iran back to the Stone Age.
最后一个人——Arta。他在伊斯法罕经营一家科技公司。Arta 的语音备忘录是最后收到的。我在听完其他所有人的录音后听了这段。它帮助我理解了一些我以前没想到的事情，关于伊朗的未来走向。Arta 对他周围那些因为特朗普总统没有履行威胁，尤其是特朗普在社交媒体上做出的把伊朗炸回石器时代的承诺而感到愤怒的人感到深深不安。
You might not believe it, but the morning the ceasefire was announced, I actually called a friend. And he picked up the phone, saying, what is this? What a mess. Why did they just let it go? I mean, believe it or not, there is a segment of society who, in my opinion, probably lack a realistic view of what returning to the Stone Age actually entails, because maybe they don't really know what it's like to live without electricity in a fifth or sixth or 10th floor apartment.
你可能不相信，但宣布停火的那天早上，我真的打给了个朋友。他接起电话说，这是什么？真是一团糟。为什么他们就这么算了？我是说，信不信由你，有一部分社会群体，在我看来，可能缺乏对回归石器时代意味着什么的现实认识，因为也许他们根本不知道住在五楼、六楼或十楼的公寓里没有电是什么感觉。
But whether it is out of intense rage or just pure, sheer ignorance, many people prefer that we go back to the Stone Age and have our energy infrastructure be completely wiped out, as long as the Islamic regime went down with it.
但不管是出于强烈的愤怒还是纯粹的无知，许多人宁愿我们回到石器时代，能源基础设施被完全摧毁，只要伊斯兰政权随之倒台就行。
So there's one group completely upset and furious, but then there's the complete opposite, the diehard loyalists ready to sacrifice their lives for the Islamic Republic. The situation is truly, it's extremely terrifying.
所以有一群人彻底愤怒了，但也有完全相反的人，那些誓死保卫伊斯兰共和国的顽固忠诚者。情况确实……极其恐怖。
And for me, who's slightly in the middle-- I completely oppose the Islamic regime. But my red lines are the destruction of my country's infrastructure and the loss of my loved ones. And aside from that, if I'm being real, I'd give my own life to see the Islamic regime gone. But I do hold these two red lines.
而对于稍微站在中间的我来说——我完全反对伊斯兰政权。但我的底线是我国家的基建设施遭到破坏以及失去我爱的人。除此以外，说实话，我愿意献出生命来看到伊斯兰政权倒台。但我确实守住这两条底线。
There's another red line Arta has held for a while now. He tells this story. And this is where I felt like, oh, that is a clue, not just about the blackout and what's happening now, but something the Iranian regime seems to have been building up for years now.
Arta 还有另一条已经坚守了一段时间的底线。他讲了这个故事。这就是我感觉到，噢，这是一个线索，不仅是关于断网和现在发生的事情，而且是伊朗政权多年来似乎一直在构建的事情。
Before the war, over a year ago, Arta was offered something he calls a white line. It's also called a white SIM card. White SIM cards are a way for Iranian officials and political leaders and regime-aligned journalists to bypass internet restrictions and access much more of the global internet than the general population ever has access to.
战前，一年多前，有人给 Arta 提供了一个他称之为“白线”的东西。也叫“白SIM卡”。白SIM卡是伊朗官员、政治领导人和亲政权记者绕过互联网限制，获取比一般民众所能接触到多得多的全球互联网的一种方式。
So even when there's an internet blackout or delays, if you have a white SIM card, you can get online. Arta had a contact who said they could get him a white card, a white line. But back then, Arta refused.
所以即使在互联网断网或延迟时，如果你有白SIM卡，你也能上网。Arta 有个联系人说他们能弄到白卡，白线。但在当时，Arta 拒绝了。
Many of my friends and former colleagues around me had white lines, and I knew it. But I resisted. I felt this is an undeniable right that all Iranian people should have, and I didn't want to use this special privilege. I wanted to stand alongside everyone else, living with the same hardships and struggles and VPNs and staying on this side, the side of the ordinary people.
我周围的许多朋友和前同事都有白线，我知道。但我拒绝了。我觉得这是所有伊朗人都应该拥有的不可剥夺的权利，我不想使用这种特殊特权。我想和大家站在一起，经历同样的困难、挣扎、VPN，留在这一边，普通人这一边。
You know what it's like? It's like using a special privilege just to have the right to eat food while the rest of your society-- your friends, your family, your siblings-- can't afford to eat meat. But because of your privilege, you do. Does that make sense? If I'm being real, I condemned a lot of my friends who used that kind of privilege. I would actually-- half jokingly, I would tell them, oh, shut up, bro, you have a white line.
你知道那是什么感觉吗？就像仅仅为了有权吃饭而使用特殊特权，而你社会其余的人——你的朋友、家人、兄弟姐妹——却买不起肉。但因为你的特权，你却可以。这有意义吗？老实说，我谴责很多使用这种特权的朋友。我甚至会半开玩笑地对他们说，噢，闭嘴吧兄弟，你有白线。
We would actually talk amongst ourselves, saying, did you see that guy had a white line too, that guy who pretended to be so aligned with the people? And I was one of the proud ones. Many of my friends told me, we thought you definitely had one, but you didn't. I held my head high.
我们甚至会在私下谈论，说，你看到那个人也有白线吗？那个假装和人民站在一条线上的人？我是那些骄傲的人之一。我很多朋友告诉我，我们以为你肯定有一个，但你没有。我昂首挺胸。
Then this war and this blackout, the longest ever. And Arta got a new offer, a new service approved by the state called Internet Pro. This would be like a white line or a white SIM card, but it would cost money, and it would give Arta a way to access the global internet. Arta is supporting his extended family. He had staff depending on him. They're an IT company. They couldn't work without the internet. So he did it. He signed up.
然后是这场战争和这次断网，有史以来最长的一次。Arta 得到了一个新的提议，国家批准的一项新服务，叫“互联网专业版”。这就像白线或白SIM卡，但需要花钱，它能给 Arta 提供访问全球互联网的方式。Arta 还要养活他大家庭。他有员工依赖他。他们是 IT 公司。没有互联网他们无法工作。所以他做了。他注册了。
This was a guy who, before the war, would not even use the domestic messaging apps in the state-run intranet. He did not want to be surveilled. Now, to get Internet Pro, Arta was required to provide his national ID number, phone number, and the names and details of everyone he works with who would be using the internet. He handed all of that in.
这是一个在战前甚至不愿在国家运行的内网使用国产消息应用的人。他不想被监视。现在，为了获得互联网专业版，Arta 被要求提供他的国家身份证号、电话号码，以及所有将使用互联网的员工的姓名和详细信息。他全交了。
Do I feel secure? No, not at all. Listen, I firmly believe their monitoring over me has increased significantly. I have absolutely no sense of security.
我感到安全吗？不，一点也不。听着，我坚信他们对我的监控已经显著增加了。我完全没有任何安全感。
Surveillance and submission are the price of access. The blackout wasn't lifted when the ceasefire was declared, and it hasn't been lifted since. It now seems more and more possible that Iran will not return the internet back to the way it was before the war, ever.
监视和服从是获取访问权的代价。停火宣布时断网并没有解除，此后也没有解除。现在看来，伊朗可能永远不会让互联网回到战前的样子了。
And instead, there's a new plan-- tiered internet access, internet as a privilege granted by the state for people who support the state, or are at least willing and able to pay a state-sanctioned company for access. It turns the internet from a public place where anyone can show up and speak, listen, argue, spread conspiracy theories, find the best tweezers, to an internet that is more like an airport lounge, a silver elite, gold-plated, platinum loyalty program.
相反，有一个新计划——分层互联网接入，互联网作为国家授予那些支持国家，或者至少愿意并有能力向国家批准的公司支付费用获取访问权的人的特权。它将互联网从一个任何人都可以出现并发表言论、倾听、争论、传播阴谋论、寻找最好镊子的地方，变成了一个更像机场贵宾休息室的地方，一个白银精英、镀金、白金忠诚度计划。
This is more and more common around the world, governments limiting internet access and sometimes going to full blackout. The whole thing has a real "coming to a country near you" vibe.
这在世界各地越来越普遍，各国政府限制互联网接入，有时甚至进行全面断网。这一切真的有一种“即将降临到你所在的国家”的感觉。
When I first listened to these voice memos from Iran, they felt to me like a rare document of a rare time, people living their lives in this temporary moment through a war and a blackout. But I think of the voice memos differently now. I think it's possible they're documenting a massive, frightening change.
当我第一次听到这些来自伊朗的语音备忘录时，它们让我觉得像是一个罕见时代的罕见文档，人们在这一临时时刻经历着战争和断网，过着他们的生活。但我现在对这些语音备忘录有不同的看法。我认为它们可能正在记录一场巨大的、可怕的变革。
That story was produced by Diane Wu.
那个故事由 Diane Wu 制作。
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu and edited by Nancy Updike. Roxana Saberi and Fatemeh Jamalpour collected the voice memos for us. They're both journalists and authors. Fatemeh's book-- For the Sun After Long Nights. You can find a link to Roxana and Fatemeh's excellent reporting on what happened in January in Iran at our website.
我们今天的节目由 Diane Wu 制作，Nancy Updike 编辑。Roxana Saberi 和 Fatemeh Jamalpour 为我们收集了这些语音备忘录。她们都是记者和作家。Fatemeh 的书——《漫漫长夜后的太阳》。你可以在我们的网站上找到 Roxana 和 Fatemeh 关于伊朗一月份发生事情的出色报道的链接。
The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan, and Christopher Swetala. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, senior editor David Kestenbaum, and our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
制作今天节目的人员包括 Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan 和 Christopher Swetala。我们的总编辑是 Sarah Abdurrahman，高级编辑 David Kestenbaum，执行编辑是 Emanuele Berry。
The actors who performed the voice memos for us-- Bahar Beihaghi, Tara Grammy, Jerry Habibi, Darius Homayoun, Ava Lalezarzadeh, Abraham Makany, Arian Moayed, Navid Negahban, Babak Tafti, Pej Vahdat, Sheila Vand, and Selina Zahednia. Our wonderful casting director-- Sabrina Hyman.
为我们表演语音备忘录的演员——Bahar Beihaghi, Tara Grammy, Jerry Habibi, Darius Homayoun, Ava Lalezarzadeh, Abraham Makany, Arian Moayed, Navid Negahban, Babak Tafti, Pej Vahdat, Sheila Vand 和 Selina Zahednia。我们出色的选角导演——Sabrina Hyman。
Special thanks today to everyone in Iran who sent us voice memos for this story. And also special thanks to Sardar Pashai, Kaveh Dastooreh, Hossein Hafezian, Durrie Bouscaren, Ahmad Ahmadian, and Mahsa Alimardani. Shirin Jaafari, who you heard at the start of the show, is a reporter on the public radio show, The World.
今天特别感谢伊朗所有为这个故事发送语音备忘录的人。还要特别感谢 Sardar Pashai, Kaveh Dastooreh, Hossein Hafezian, Durrie Bouscaren, Ahmad Ahmadian 和 Mahsa Alimardani。你在节目开头听到的 Shirin Jaafari 是公共广播节目《世界》（The World）的记者。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Please consider supporting the show as a This American Life Partner. You will get regular exclusive bonus episodes. You can listen ad free and more. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX 公共广播交换平台发送给各公共电台。请考虑作为《美国生活》的合作伙伴支持本节目。你将获得定期的独家加长剧集。你可以无广告收听及更多权益。请在 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners 加入。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是 Chana Joffe-Walt。下周我们将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。